- So the impeachment trial is over
and no witnesses were called.
This is the second time there's been
an impeachment in the last year
with no witnesses being called.
But there's several reasons
why the house managers
might not have wanted to call witnesses.
First of all, Congress says
they wanna get back to governing.
I think they should be able
to do two things at once.
But, more the point,
they were worried about
what the witnesses would have said.
Most of the witnesses with
extremely relevant information
would have been close to the Trump camp
and who knows what they would have said.
But this is the classic
trial lawyer's dilemma,
you never know what a witness
is going to say on the stand!
But you could have ameliorated that
by taking depositions of those witnesses
to know ahead of time what
their testimony would be.
And while this was unfortunate,
the evidence was overwhelming.
I would have liked to have seen
more of a factual record with witnesses,
but, look, the evidence was there.
But what do I know? I'm just a lawyer.
And, speaking of which, subscribe
or I'll see you in court.